oh man my name welcome back to the more
happy whereas I am circus I did not go
well I'm sitting so low on this computer
- come on man grab it yeah I'm a circus
queen I mean bow yeah yeah I'm Dutch
well I got your pain as [ __ ] hey don't
touch my pee okay you can touch my we
can both cut back oh I got your all
right don't mind a pause nipple twist
for the victory that was awesome make a
full version Oh
epic no mom well know that SR can now I
play this get damn it alright goalkeeper
in slow-mo
here comes blockage yeah did you shave
it down god this is lame oh I'm flying
I'm flying do that oh yeah got it
yeah pop alright finally they made a
good buddies come on why am i flying I
dunno why am I not flying okay okay I
got it timing yeah what what wow alright
good time good time alright but I'll run
mad man what the [ __ ] man what the
blonde flip holy [ __ ] did you see that
oh my god I don't think I'm supposed oh
no my [ __ ] exploded it happens should
happen alright here we go
yeah we go
ah but I can make that beginning [ __ ]
yeah front flip still live [ __ ] I'm
dancing this is my victory dance [ __ ]
yeah to the left to the left to the
right to the right
I'm weird virus let's do that [ __ ]
alright this oh he makes some pretty
cool mats so this should be good
alright well daddy's going out what
happened yeah they good
oh no it's a virus whoa no just check
what you are my new best don't listen to
this batter okay he's lying
trust me the virus is taking over I
can't control him on problem result
please go in this holler you have no
choice
all right I like go anyhow now please
remove your brain someone will be coming
collect the shirt the hint there is a
way to get out of here ah-ha remove my
brain uh-huh how how much were those do
drat best back take me after I let me
clap well that's not much of a hint just
to dump it
harpoon Ravan hold up are you ready for
I'm ready [ __ ] [ __ ] I hold up what's
the problem
I guess I got a release and then hold up
all right here we got grab it Oh nearly
yeah nipple rubbing slide ah yeah
land of night let's do it welcome to
don't care
acrobatic Hebei all right thank that
kiss me son all right
oh yeah you like this son yes actually
it does me piece of [ __ ] all right
I repeat our head back and far-off
trans-neptunian
you sir now bad [ __ ] my arms are lost
no no I block them arms blocka blocka
son of a-- Sturrock god damn it come on
[Music]
what did you say is there a problem back
here learning it for gay paper all right
wait no no no I want to finish that one
that one's awesome maybe it's better if
we do another character run another
stretch do you think I can say Oh secret
pathway of hidden coins take it right up
your alley
that's right that's how you complete
just bit Christmas run why not
Oh run your little [ __ ] I mean
granulator nothing hey Paula well hello
hey nice nice oh thank you photo all
right nice Paula are you riding with me
now yet it does whoa
sandy front flip cut sandy all right
gotta get Bob justice this well I gotta
head stock is rolling back whoa whoa
whoa sandy power sander powers
oh that's how we roll in Santa land
that's right
[ __ ] yeah now where the [ __ ] is that
other one go it connected to we will
never know
dad Plus chrome demo all right well what
the hell are you doing that hello
everyone this is only a demo all right
that doesn't mean you can't do [ __ ] new
idea suggestions
no I'm not interested I'm sorry can we
play something that's actually fun now
we don't get type things
oh three the PI's nightmare there's
actually a custom story of coal gaming
that's actually mine I don't got all
right then yeah finally
that little [ __ ] it's pretty
[Laughter]
good-looking mine [ __ ] Matt grabbing
NEFAs look at you buy like a yeah
[ __ ] best front flip over that's how
I roll doctor have the i-x know exactly
what happened what the hell is this
giving me a beat what get off me boy
whoa whoa
you're something what you're some I get
your nipple what beautiful sorry about
that bro my nipples are bleeding but
that's okay what are you doing here yeah
no wait what dad what's going on here
because it's not a beautiful come on you
know we are breasts
we don't care all right so don't I yeah
yeah I mean it all right I mean I'm a
today I don't you can yeah [ __ ] sake
get down all right you gotta read I have
a hatchet
I am stronger than ya know yeah well
okay you are but whatever that's a
pretty [ __ ]
Noah [ __ ] with my son except me yeah
goddamn he is really strong enemy come
on oh that's how I ride that's how I get
to the ladies that's right I get all the
[ __ ] know I get down the pit stop
[ __ ] my [ __ ] you can [ __ ] me if you
want I mean no but oh just give [ __ ]
sake man [ __ ] the bike if you honored
how am I still alive that's [ __ ]
question about everything in life all
right Vic it slide under yes and [ __ ]
the lady yes I did it actually no I
missed come at me bro
[ __ ] which way this way I can take it
all right I'll go this way
I suspect nothing here you bet
alright I'll go back what Dad holy [ __ ]
it could really is Atlantan yeah I could
good oh my gosh Espada where have you
been so far I missed you bro what the
hell Oh what is that nice please I came
so far I came so far faster he'll catch
how the [ __ ] does it with it ah I'm so
startled now he's run over a bush
[ __ ] teleported naked guys this is
we're dissolved what Helena guy don't
scissor doing weird position what the
hell is not your my wash [ __ ] alright
run out of the poo it's finally up
insert brofist here that was the best
map ever played holy [ __ ] that was epic
thank you both so much for making that I
really appreciate all the maps you make
for me it's it's really that a lot of
fun
you both showing your support in
whatever way you do guy I really
appreciate it
all right let's do I think I'm out of
time I shoulda so I think it's perfect
way to end it here like videos you
enjoyed subscribe to come abroad today
and I'll just you next episode of around
my right I don't know hey lady